under the direction of the administrator
of Veterans Affairs Veterans
Administration is making every effort
towards furnishing ex-servicemen with
the benefits of early diagnosis and the
prompt and skillful treatment of cancer
this paired hospital at hi Angela noise
provides more than 400 beds for tumor
cases and serves as a training ground
for physicians selected to specialize in
the diagnosis and treatment of this
disease leaving the beautiful and
spacious grounds we enter the hospital
where the tumor board is in session
and hear the voice of dr. max cups
consultants in tumors at the hinds
facilities who will present his subjects
the early diagnosis of cancer dr. Cutler
early diagnosis is the keystone to
cancer control and accurate diagnosis is
of no avail unless the lesion is
recognized early and treated correctly
before it has become disseminated thus
early diagnosis resulting in the
elimination of precancerous conditions
and in the cure of early cancer is by
far the most important single factor and
the cure ability of this disease the
external cancers can be detected in
their very early stages and are both
preventable and curable the internal
cancer unfortunately presents a much
more complex problem and although much
can be accomplished by careful attention
to early diagnosis real progress in this
group awaits the discovery of a
diagnostic test much more delicate than
is now available we will now consider
three forms of cancer which tests
through definite precancerous stages and
are therefore not only durable but
presentable cancer of the mouth preceded
by leukoplakia
cancer of the skin preceded by
hyperkeratosis and melanoma preceded by
apparently innocent mole we begin with
leukoplakia
one of our most simple
precancerous conditions this region is
ten times as common in men as in women
hence 90% of cancers of the mouth occur
in men the well-known relation between
tobacco and leukoplakia has given rise
to the term smokers patch here you see a
leukoplakia of the mucous membrane of
the cheeks in which smoking is the
etiological factor an underlying
susceptibility of the tissues to
nicotine must be present for leukoplakia
to develop in susceptible individuals it
is probable that infant decimal amounts
of the stimulating chemical agents can
result in this condition the
relationship between leukoplakia and
cancer is well illustrated in this case
where you see an intense radiation
reaction after treatment of a cancer of
the right cheek which develops in a pack
of leukoplakia leukoplakia often occurs
at the sites of artificial dentures as
in this case here we see a diffused
leukoplakia of the roof of the mouth in
a patient whose mucous membrane is
evidently susceptible to chronic
irritation and to nicotine a combination
of factors is usually responsible for
this type of leader when a patch of
leukoplakia begins to undergo malignant
degeneration it exhibits certain
clinical and it becomes thickened and
some foot indurated and its surface
becomes assured and eroded in this stage
the lesion is either precancerous are
already fully malignant true ulceration
almost invariably means that carcinoma
has become established when these
clinical signs appear a biopsy is
usually necessary to establish the
diagnosis of cancer in this connection
it should be emphasized that a negative
biopsy by no means excludes the presence
of cancer and one must be guided largely
by the clinical picture dental caries is
Ethio logically related to cancer of the
oral mucous membrane
a sharp or broken tooth can produce
repeated trauma to the adjacent mucous
membranes and results in a traumatic
ulcer and finally in carcinoma this is a
remarkable example of this fact notes
the precise relationship between this
jagged tooth and the lesion and the
mucous membrane of the cheek removal of
the source of irritation results in pump
disappearance of the ulcer when it is
only inflammatory leukoplakia of the
oral mucous membrane frequently arises
at the site of dissimilar metal fillings
in patients who are non-smokers and in
the absence of both nonspecific
inflammation and syphilis the
development of the leukoplakia at the
exact site of the dissimilar fillings as
in this case and the absence of other
etiologic factors constitutes
significant evidence of this probable
relationship the lateral border of the
tongue being in close proximity to
curious and infected teeth is a common
sight of leukoplakia the dorsum is
detected more commonly when the lesion
is diffuse walk when it is on a
syphilitic basis extensive diffuse
leukoplakia is usually associated with
syphilis the cancers of the lips and
tongue are quite independent each arose
in a separate batch of local places such
lesions may arise simultaneously or they
may be separated by months or years the
prognosis of cancer of the mouth
associated with syphilitic leukoplakia
is extremely grave the modification in
the connective tissue and blood vessels
resulting from the syphilitic infection
as a most unfavorable influence upon the
surgical and radiation results and a
cures almost never accomplished in spite
of the efficiency and thoroughness of
the treatment in spite of the early
signs they produce cancers of the oral
cavity still reached an advanced stage
in many patients the last two cases are
examples of this fact cancer of the
lower lip is overwhelmingly a disease of
men the lesion begins as a small
localized nodularity
has to be differentiated from a benign
hyper keratosis lesions of this extent
are readily curable by surgery or by
irradiation in later stages the disease
spreads to the adjacent skin and oral
mucosa and the lesion becomes indurated
ulcerated and painful as in this example
lesions of this extent are usually
accompanied by cervical adenopathy and
when the growth approaches or crosses
the midline one must assume that the
adenopathy is bilateral even though this
is not demonstrable clinical a
projecting - especially when it's a
shark
sometimes dramatizes the lips causing
freshed an ulcer
then a carcinoma this is a clinical
example note the precise anatomical
relation between the tooth and the
carcinoma
cancer can begin in the mucous membrane
of the upper or lower lip or cheek as a
small firm circumscribed and movable
tumor which grows slowly and remains non
ulcerated for a long time these lesions
are originated in the epithelium of
ducts of mucous glands because they are
not all serrated and freely movable they
resemble simple benign mucous tips and
are invariably so diagnosed they are
usually removed inadequately and recur
promptly they are often highly malignant
and unless this peculiar types of
carcinoma is diagnosed properly and
treated correctly the first time the
results are disastrous
the differential diagnosis of cancer of
the mouth must consider benign papilloma
this lesions primary and tertiary
syphilis papilloma dirham of the tongue
tuberculosis and mixed tumors of
salivary glands here we have two cases
of tuberculosis of the mouth the
brachial osis of the tongue is rare when
it occurs it is usually associated with
an active pulmonary leader tuberculous
ulcerations appears as a flat non
indurated lesion which is painful and
tender the ulcer lacks the surrounding
infiltration and in duration which is so
characteristic of carcinoma when the
nature of the lesion is in doubt
clinically a biopsy should be performed
to establish the diagnosis with
certainty the aberrant salivary glands
give rise to an interesting and peculiar
group of tumors in the mouth these
tumors arise within the cheek the lip
the base of the tongue and the soft
palate salivary gland tumors of the soft
palate may reach a large size as seen in
this case the small tumors are generally
cured by wide surgical removal
inadequate excision is followed by
prompt recurrence when these tumors
reach a large size and occur in older
individuals the patient's comfort and
life expectancy are often benefited by a
conservative course the chief point in
the differential diagnosis are their
location their slow growth and the fact
that they remain circumscribed for long
periods unlike the carcinomas they
remain on ulcerated for many years in
spite of their large size there are
three main types of skin cancer this is
the basal cell form and is commonly
referred to as rodent ulcer the next is
the squamous cell type with horn
application and thrill formation and the
third is the adenoid cystic type which
is usually classified as a sub variety
of basal cell cancer the majority of
cancers of the skin occur on the face
adenoids cystic carcinoma of the skin is
a form of basal cell cancer this type is
often multiple and commonly affects the
eyelids forehead and nose the lesions
are first elevated then ulcerated as a
rule there are more radio resistance
than the typical basal cell carcinomas
the nose is a common site of cancer of
the skin the majority are of the basal
cell type regional metastasis generally
does not occur until the lesion has
involved the mucous membrane a great
effort should be made to cure these skin
lesions at the first attempt for each
recurrence presents greater and greater
difficulties the first therapeutic
procedure be it surgery or irradiation
generally steals the patient's face the
crucial importance of eradicating the
disease the first time can hardly be
exaggerated advanced lesions such as
these can be avoided only by early
diagnosis and thorough treatment when
the patient first comes under
observation here is a basal cell
carcinoma of the lower eyelid the lesion
is early and easily curable a surface
application of radium administered under
correct conditions results in almost
certain cure the dose must be the
maximum which the normal tissues will
tolerate here is a basal cell carcinoma
of the nose which has been treated and
is beginning to undergo repair note that
the edges of the lesion have disappeared
seventy-five percent of chances of the
eyelid are of the basal cell type
regional lymph node metastasis occurs in
20% the inner campus of the lower eyelid
is the most common site in this case a
carcinoma of the left lower eyelid had
disappeared after irradiation but the
sterilization was incomplete and several
years later an extension of the disease
developed adequately radiation as a rule
avoids this complication here we see one
of the great tragedies
this disease how long did this patient
wait before consulting his physician did
the physician choose the best method of
treatment how accurately and skillfully
was the treatment executed these are the
searching questions we as physicians
must constantly keep the forests
carcinomas of the scalp grow very slowly
and almost never invade the region of
lymph nodes they tend to adhere to the
underlying bone and are usually fresh
seen in their late stages curable in the
beginning these lesions ultimately
destroy the bone and involve the
meninges and the brain note the
pulsation of the brain in this tragic
case and now we come to the story of
what can happen to an apparently
innocent mole there are few tragedies in
the whole realm of Medicine that equal
the complications which sometimes
develop in connection with these
apparently innocent lesions since the
average individual harbors about 20
moles the malignant transformation of a
mole is comparatively rare traumatism
plays an important role in transforming
the course of a benign nevis moles which
are so located as to be subjected to
repeated trauma and moles showing
clinical signs of activity should be
treated by careful and complete surgical
removal you have just seen a fleshy
pedunculated mole a type which is
removed without danger the hairy
non-segmented mole belongs to the same
category pigmented macules are common
and may be single or multiple they may
be present at birth or developed later
in life the danger of melanoma is slight
they should be removed only on the
indications mention it is the flat
bluish black or brownish black mole that
is the most dangerous of all and here we
see a remarkable example of malignant
transformation of a bluish black mold
metastases to the regional lymph nodes
are already present microscopic
examination of a melanoma may disclose
all the cellular features without
showing the presence of pigment or the
characteristic Brown intracellular
pigment may form a striking feature of
the microscopic picture as you see in
this photo micrograph extensive
metastases to the axillary lymph nodes
has occurred in this case following
excision of a pigmented mole on the left
forearm
sometimes invasion remains limited to
one or two regional lymph nodes for a
long time and it is in this group that
radical dissection has resulted in
apparent cure in isolated case the scar
on the left forearm indicates the site
of excision of the primary melanoma
melanoma may affect the scalp and
metastasize to regional lymph nodes as
in this case metastases to axillary and
supraclavicular glands also occurred in
this case following traumatic treatment
of a mole on the left arm electrode
desiccation is uncertain and probably
dangerous careful and complete surgical
excision offers the safest course the
presence of small secondary nodules
around a melon otic tumor is an
important sign of its malignant nature
the heel is a favorite site for
melanomas this lesion was already
accompanied by pulmonary metastasis when
first examined in discussing early
diagnosis it is necessary to review the
steps to which a lesion passes the board
becomes malignant in other words we must
attempt to form a mental picture of the
nature of the cancer process we are now
fairly certain that cancer is not a
sudden event or an accident in a
previously normal tissue but on the
contrary it is the result of a series of
changes which may have begun many years
before a combination of factors seems
necessary for the initiation of abnormal
growth hereditary susceptibility
unquestionably plays a part an excess or
deficiency of certain hormones and
probably the
presence of certain chemicals we call
carcinogenic agents combine to initiate
excessive growth of cells we have
learned the remarkable fact that
abnormal cell growth need not
necessarily result in clinical cancer at
one extreme the growth may be so rapid
as to overwhelm the individual in a
short period of a few months and at the
other extreme the growth may be so slow
that the patient does not live long
enough to develop clinical cancer and he
dies of other causes harboring one or
more free cancerous lesion thus certain
precancerous lesions required 10 years
others 20 years til others 30 years to
reach the stage of clinical cancer and
it is well known that the older we get
the more chances we have of developing
this disease there is also considerable
evidence to indicate that precancerous
lesions can regress and perish in the
body as a result of some defensive
mechanism the nature of which we do not
yet understand and it is probable that
even fully established cancers can under
certain conditions cease to grow regress
and even disappear when we use the term
precancerous we generally think of it in
microscopic terms we mean a lesion which
exhibits all the morphological features
of cancer but which has not yet escaped
outside normal boundaries we must
remember however that the morphological
appearance of a cell is a very crude
index of its biological state and even a
less accurate guide as to its future
intention thus the group of neoplastic
epithelial cells confined within the
normal boundaries of a duct of the
breast may be ready to invade the
lymphatics and blood vessels immediately
or they may remain stationary for many
years
or they may regress and disappear and
yet the microscope as a rule can neither
distinguish these cells nor predict
their future thus it is evidence that
cancer is a highly complex clinical
pathological and biological problem
through the medical and hospital service
the Veterans Administration has
developed over the past 10 years an
organization for the study and treatment
of cancer that is unique in the world in
addition to the hinds tumor clinic there
are five subsidiary units in the five
geographical areas into which the
country is divided each representing a
unit organized equipped and man to offer
to the veterans suffering with cancer
the latest knowledge in the diagnosis
and treatment of this disease and
elaborate system of records is
maintained and a register of tumor cases
has been established which permits a
study of the results of treatment in
addition to highly-trained full-time
personnel all six units have consulting
staffs composed of some of the leading
experts in their field whose help and
advice are available when special
problems arise the Heinz facility is not
only a hospital but is a practical
governmentally controlled training
school as well for doctors it presents a
broad opportunity to study diseases
inviting new method of eliminating
suffering for patients the library
facilities and the many phases of
properly supervised occupational therapy
such as wood carving weaving metalwork
recreation etc offer a greater
incentives to develop new channels of
thinking today this great facility at
Heinz is considered the largest
government hospital of the Veterans
Administration and monument which should
continually inspire us to strive to
conquer this dread disease it is with
such institutions as this that the
helping hand of the United States
government extended through the Veterans
Administration practically demonstrates
its appreciation of the spirit and
loyalty of its veterans